okay I see that nicca Mitch are getting
seated so I will start by saying good
afternoon everybody and welcome once
again to the Android developers office
hours emea addition we are the the emea
based android developer relations team
I'm Sparky I'm coming to you from Munich
Germany and I'm also joined by my
colleagues Nick and rich who are
visiting in where are you in Tel Aviv is
that where you are they were coming
slightly blurry for from Tel Aviv please
don't clean your webcams or screens or
anything we just have a slightly lower
quality internet connection today
hopefully the audio comes through ok
we're also joined by his neck this blur
here next book and this one's mine
bridge and we're joined by a blur on the
far left or far right of you guys of
Yossi from FUBU who is been joining us
at the gvg meeting in Israel here hey
y'all see Wow imagine being together
with him everything yeah this week he's
live with us he was going to join anyway
right just consume more bandwidth so you
guys will drink from the same room
that's terrific well I can see you guys
pretty well as long as you hold stock
still so so lean back on those support
braces that you got yourselves built and
and don't move a muscle and your picture
will be just fine okay oh and that is
asking to be invited into the Hangout
how do I do that you got it I hear that
all right so so I see that we're already
joined by several people live in the
Hangout we got yet al we got arts from
me God Ravi we knew else has just joined
us Ravi Tommy and Richard so that runs
out who's live and I hang out right now
do any of you have anything Android
related that you would like to talk
about this week cuz chickadees party
where I was not asking is he on the
geology desperate now he just pinged me
oh he just turned the
chatty must be n enjoy strong sucker he
pretty bad I'll come about there are
some pretty posh digs you got there mad
is that where you're here oh please feel
free to go ahead and ask your question
you're gonna ask it live or asked in the
chat what I want you p a bully bald bald
an assertive and ass ask her questions
because I've only got five questions
queued up on the moderator so of you if
you fall back on the moderator we're
going to exhaust our are prepared
material quite quickly we have a plan if
we run that for ped material we can go
around we've got a hackathon running
here at the moment of Israel we can go
around with our show the internet
connection and see what people are up to
at the Android he doesn't read packet Oh
get me back across ah cool no re has
typed the window maybe he has no
microphone uh I'll got a lower third
what is going on I thought I'd give it a
try this week I could turn it off if you
guys want no I'm afraid I want one of
those I'll tell you how to get it in the
chat bar key yeah are you using one of
the Hangout plugins for that hello a
third again yeah I am it's I need just
discovered it a couple of days ago so
here so everyone should start doing that
no more easily asking I want to play a
sound when a user clicks on a button
using a sound phone it is working well
except on my HTC it's well except on
your own device it doesn't care to sound
out yet with visible or more than three
seconds a person that activity butcher
huh so it works unless the activities
being visible for more than three
seconds or get way around it doesn't
doesn't a racist way back at all your
hard work Bobcat audio hardware in cm
playback is going to stand by so it
works if you hit the button within the
first three seconds and after that
doesn't work anymore are you pretty much
using the example code for sound fall
I'm only used it a couple of times
myself but I just grabbed the sample
code printed in and used it and it was
fine have you checked Stack Overflow to
this particular issue with your we do a
bit of luck out there hmm sorry I'm
talking to a chat window live on air
right now I'm reading the chats back
Harry says yes I've check stack overflow
and yes he's talking about his activity
which one pupillary now I don't know
anything about it well he's what I
stackoverflow ish you yeah alright well
it's great that we have a stack overflow
case I don't know if we're going to be
able to really sort through it Lions
Jimmer okay take a look he doesn't need
samples can go to sleep it does seem to
indicate they'd device-specific in let's
knock out my questions so maybe a
problem with HTC's implementation or
some of the binary packages they're
using on some of their devices that
sound falls are pretty often used class
I would have thought if HTC it spoke it
up the implementation stone for we'd
know about it it does say that he's
using on vorbis so you know that's
that's open source you can't trust that
stuff
I try to use a manipulator object and
see if after prepare you'll still have
the object ready for you
same result with mediafire area now when
will the waste of our goods across the
hall with the bottom three well I need
one too I don't think I could ever
seeing a live hangout hosting yeah I I'm
drawn a blank on this one I don't know
and this this is not exactly my forte
creating a notification with the sound
work but that's I'm just gonna take the
flight sir about the chemical does some
pretty hockey in the other hand it
sounds like a pretty clever hack okay um
we don't have an answer for you for that
right there are in sorry I have the head
issues like that with the sound for
myself but again I haven't tested on
that device so I'll have a quick look
around whilst we go to a moderator
question for a runner read out the first
moderated question for your better
internet many others barking sugar first
question a moderator is now that Google
Cloud messaging is in place is there any
recommended way of benchmarking out an
app behaves for large numbers of
receivers before going live that's sort
of an interesting question because it's
only peripherally Android related right
the that I think what he's you if you're
talking about load testing really what
you're looking for is your you are
testing out the web app really the
server based application not the android
client and yeah it's it's it's a it's a
web service so i would say test it out
the way you would test out any web
service probably abstracto the android
clients and maybe just use some kind of
a web-based load testing tool or an
expect script or a python script or
something and a hammer at it purely with
network-based requests that's that's my
answer that one as far as the google
cloud messaging part goes
you know that's the google cloud
messaging is a service that we are
providing more or less as is and either
it can handle your loader at kent and we
think it can so GCM at least as far as
its load testing part isn't really part
of your system under test it's really
our system under test so all that you
need to worry about is your android
client and your server app and the
server app you can basically test using
you know traditional network testing
utilities it's also probably worth
mentioning that with GCM it's not worth
assuming that if you send a message out
he's going to receive it quickly because
people can be out of service areas and
have their device is turned off so bold
cloud testing like that's not really the
best way to go it's probably better to
test the logic on the client side for
discarding messages which have either
expired or out-of-date or no longer
relevant right messages have been bashed
up like you yeah and of course Google
Cloud messaging is designed to not be a
reliable protocol meaning we make no
guarantees at all that every message
will be delivered or the messages will
be delivered in a timely manner or in
order I I like to tell people think of
it more like UDP rather than TCP packets
can arrive in any order some of them can
be lost and you should design the
information that you're packing into the
data to take into account the
possibility that not everything will get
through for instance rather than sending
a GCM message that says you know here is
the content of your mail you sent a GCM
message saying since the last time you
contacted the server you have twenty
seven new messages here's a little URL
so that you can get your twenty seven
new messages um if that one gets lost
and number 28 29 and 30 come in you send
another one that says since the last
time you contact the server you now have
30 new messages and that way your
messages can be cumulative and
you aren't reliant on every single one
getting through your things think about
if you are worried about you know send
the GCM and looks at an hour so it goes
to thousands of people and you're
worried about them hiring a server you
can build in some shitty code either
like don't clear to everyone at once now
you know but I'm phase it so you you're
playing GTM different pacific time or in
your client code broadcast out to
everyone and an accent jitter you're in
your client folks that may be family
over a minute you'll you'll call and get
us here so there's not getting hammered
with 10,000 get requests all the one so
something to consider and also one of
the new features of juicy m / care after
devices jingles you can now specify the
time to live for the messages to make
sure you put that make it relevant to
your application so messages that would
have expired don't actually end up
getting delivered and you'll reduce the
load that way as well and people who
turn on their handsets later on in the
morning okay I think that covers that
one does anyone else have a question
from inside the Hangout all right we got
Ravi happy what's up hi guys how are you
doing good thank you for name yeah um
yeah I've been part of Google Hangouts
the week before and yeah I'm really
excited to join you guys back again not
to waste any more time but I just had a
quick question I know I don't know if
this sounds are they stupid but pardon
me if it does i have an application
which we are extending into a tablet
edition and I know what's really hunting
us is the screen resolutions where as
for the the developer guide given in
developer.android.com the actual screen
sizes were differentiated or generalized
sizes were small normal large and
x-large and the ad aspect density they
say ldp
I mdpi hdpi an xhdpi in this instance I
would I see some of the 7-inch tablet
devices or some of the devices which I
was having a 7 inch screen taken HDD
hdpi assets whereas some devices which
are having a 4.7 inch screen such as s3
is taking xhdpi assets I'm not quite
sure what strategy I just need to lay in
order to fit the back best layout with
the best assets device it's gotta be
speaking having cleanly supporting
multiple screens page on developer
android com it gives a good outline I
was rubbish werster I have a have seen
the developers Android site and I've
also seen the supporting multiple
screens and stuff but I mean when when I
when I act literally doing some
development and it's okay when we are
doing it via an emulator and checking it
over some quite a few test devices but
when we send the app over the market
where I mean Android devices are being
in thousands of numbers and and and we
are not we are unable to figure the way
where we we need to strategize the way
so I mean in some cases we just need to
specifically set some standards for a
specific device and release APK to the
Sun Zoomer and send it to him which is
taking hell loads of business I mean
develop reverse so I might think if you
would help on this assay what's the
issue I get the impression from ravi the
one in my building a bit confusion is
the difference between densities of
assets and screen sizes it's best to use
you think of those as two different
things so the density of assets is about
how much d
one and the twin size is your layout
that you want to incorporate so that way
when you come across something like an
s3 it's using the high-density assets
but it's still using the right layout
for the its size screen right yeah
exactly so as a lot of riff on what L is
saying basically you have see a visual
thing like a button background or an
icon and you say I want this thing to be
about you know two centimeters across
and then you design a bitmap that
measures about two centimeters across in
each of you know say three or four
bitmap or pixel densities so you say
this thing is is at 300 dots per inch or
two hundred dots per inch or 160 dots
per inch this is how many pixels across
the image needs to be in order to
measure say two centimeters in real
distances and so you just have different
versions of every visual asset and let
the Android device no its own screen
density and say okay I on em xdp I xhdpi
device I will pick this one or I am an
mdpi device I'll pick that one and and
you can then trust that when that thing
is grown on the screen it is
approximately two centimeters across
subject to Lou minor variations because
of the different size buckets and then
so you you sighs your assets for the
density and you sighs your layouts for
the actual size so you say i want this
is the loud i want to use if the screen
actually physically measures seven
inches across or 10 inches across or
whatever and then rely on the device to
pick and choose the right combination of
layout / its screen size and the
individual asset elements based on its
pixel density did that make sense and
whenever you do new layouts make sure
you're working in phipps is that lets
you not think about density just think
about size we do you scream out to make
sure you're working and divide the
intensity
pixels all the layout oh yeah but when
i'm doing the assets the screen
resolution which i use for the assets is
like as specified in in developer
android com which is a normal screen has
for 70 x 320 and large screens have 640
480 and using this aspect ratio we are
descending the assets where you cannot
expect all mdpi devices would having
would be having the same screen
resolution so I think this is where I am
making a mistake yeah I've include the
site if you've quoted other screen sizes
not the densities so I'll then define
your layout the densities are if you
look on the same page it'll say mdpi and
the range is about 150 to 200 dots per
inch right and that's what you used to
determine your asset sizes and how much
detail you want to put in those assets
the sizes you're talking about the 640
480 the 473 20 that's for designing the
actual whole layout of the screen rather
than designing your assets and how much
detail you want to appear in those
assets right I got it enough yes
dimensions as well like we talked but a
normal thing I guess the most common
thing out there is you know normal
identity to creating lemon and then i
wouldn't ever think about it dimension
so it's always always always think about
how big that is in dips and when you're
doing it is mine use the value the depth
value is an excellent dimensions that
fortunately the screen support document
does talk about be peace rather than
actual pixels so hopefully it's
reinforcing next message yeah there's a
great training for well that should be
all right that's that's trillion guys
and of course if you if you have further
questions feel free to look us up on
google+ and send a little message to
google plus or something like that or
take your question to stack overflow or
to the android developers forum where
people will be happy to to help answer
your questions for you there as well
thank you all right does anyone else
want to ask us a question in the forum
before we turn to the moderator again I
go on to throw across the mat I saw the
announcement yesterday about google TV
rolling out to Germany France and the
Netherlands do you know if that's going
to be the same android version as is
currently available on the sony player
in the UK in the States but so it will
be a different version the ones so the
Rosens been released in the UK Germany
and Netherlands is really different from
the one in the States there's a couple
of bits they've got over there that we
haven't got quite yet over here the it
will be different but only slightly cool
I so somewhere going to be put up that
says what the differences will be so
that people coding for global google to
google TV can tweak their apps
accordingly i will make sure that that
happens but ultimately it'll be things
like the EPG concept slider that's not
going to be there are things like that
again until eventually bring it out so
yeah but i'll make sure it ends up some
cool thanks no wise so what are you
working on can I ask and i was i was
looking at working on some social banked
applications with google TV so kind of
chatting about TV shows but using second
screen on a phone and things like that
but if the EPG stuff isn't around it
makes it a little difficult to determine
which programs on and therefore really
get sort of hashtags and stuff relating
to that program but yeah i can tweak it
there's other ways of approaching it and
it was a bit of a shot to see that
there's no google+ app for Google TV yet
yes I know I suppose you can crowdsource
I couldn't yoel you can just sort of
monitor which tags are out there and
what a whole bunch in one particular
themes start appearing you can guess
that that show has begun yeah the only
issue with that kind of comes when
you've got people who are watching the
less popular channels because you get
the popular TV program like x factor or
some talent show you get someone who's
watching
I think there's a number of ways you can
kind of go with it I things each box is
the main one that's that they think
really target specific chosen their app
so yeah it'll be interesting to see what
you come up with I'll put you on the
beta list wait for the better and when
you patent the idea remember that you
heard it here first so you can't sue us
I'm sure in the states is patented
already somewhere so I wanted to ask
them out since you were talking about
Google TV a little bit do you want to
just give us like the quick you know the
twenty ten thousand foot overview of of
what is in the new Google TV platform
and how does it relate to Android what
version is it based on and what new
capabilities does it give us and so at
the moment Google TV is running 3.22
it's still honeycomb but essentially
we've added a loaded actually work for
media codec so it kind of means that
we've given a load of extra hooks for
people are sharing media so you can
actually work out what the quality of
extreme is we're also adding in support
for like play ready drm as well as
allowing contact by the script around
here insulations we also got libraries
to help to second screen applications so
you can easily integrate the phone
tablet system then you can either
communicate over a socket or using
tensor century 25 content on the TV on
the mobile client and we're just
developing a lot of extra tools that
essentially help develop it in terms of
you I we're desperate to make sure
they're not just getting tablet your
eyes that are for it across without
focused States being enabled which
obviously for the TV that relies on
d-pad is quite important see ya and
where the moment our main focus is just
get any international lords going in
Paris Germany Netherlands in the UK I've
just come from Ephraim Berlin where we
just had something announce you be this
heavy launching in the UK and hopefully
other country seen by sense as well pick
we going international I hope
and yeah there's lots of stuff going on
the moment lots and lots of devices
coming out so lots of things has to lift
the pace that's fantastic now a couple
minutes ago and you mentioned content
providers choosing their own drm
solutions I assume that you're talking
about people who provide TV shows and
stuff not not services that that save up
front databases right is that a
different kind of content provider yeah
yeah yeah definitely man apologies yeah
definitely anyone who's kind of thought
video or audio content and it kind of
brought their own dear installation
intimately is it is kind of a niche area
but if you surprised the number of
people that have niche content that
they're def publishing like we've got a
company that's in the u.s. that
distributes Korean TV shows and we had
them at Google i/o and their main sort
of demonstration show was sex in the
city but with guys instead of of women
and apparently like it's really hot
bourbon on us so yeah interesting right
yeah I'm got starring role in that lady
get mad no yeah i'm working on emailing
and filling the right strings see all
right let's take another word from the
moderator it's been a little a little
while I'd see a view mall says can we
make application which acts like an
application locker other applications
only get accessible after providing
password if yes they can provide a hint
etc well maybe I mean one of the things
to keep in mind is that our Terms of Use
say that you can't you can't provide an
application that functions as an app
store and distribute it through google
play so if it's going to be like an app
store you would have to distribute it
some other way we're perfectly okay with
your writing those apps you just can't
distribute them through us the other
thing is I suppose yeah sure you could
you could tie it into for example the
the license verification library but
were you going to say someone else Hiram
imperfection side definitely i had
device so you can actually implement
this is your own and of lawn chair i
think a it's the launcher which offers
up the unit shortcut cilantro that all
the apps so if you wanted to provide a
customized experience which required a
partner to do that zero as a launcher
but at the same time you have to be very
careful because we do have a clause in
the developer distribution agreement
which means states you are not allowed
to interfere with other applications the
way they work or the data that they use
so when you're trying to lock this
application behind the password I just
be quite careful that maybe it's double
impossible to run the application other
manners certainly shouldn't you know
muck about the application data or
anything to do with the way the
application itself is stored if any
complaints come in saying that your
application is affecting their
application there that you could get
taken down for it so do it a safe
family-friendly manner see I think I
used to be ready today's question a
third way which was essentially
detecting before the application is
actually launched and then essentially
throwing up a password screen before
that and then preventing it from wanting
otherwise if the parcel has an injured
yeah but that would be a function of the
launcher right I mean I read it a fourth
way which is along the lines of using a
password to get access to content
provider data so is there a way of
requiring one application to provide a
password before it can get access to
danger from a content providing from a
second application okay well ah vmail
you've divided us four ways some heaven
I think I think the
what it means is the used to be a way to
see the activity manager log on a log
file polluted city system logs and sit
in dense being broadcast is out to see
the case is being launched and when the
activity was being launched you just to
tender intend and show your lock screen
and when we was interested locks and in
the Bobcat is now blocked so no one can
leave the system log is given if they
have a permission so application locker
room walk the same tissue exactly okay
basically you just look for the package
name after you said the lock feature
then you search the package name on the
look at and then when the intent is
broadcasted them you showed wrong screen
instead of their apps me yeah whatever
they don't get the pastor that you kill
the application yeah yeah you don't kill
the application you just send it as a
councilmember send their home intent so
the apps won't get actually the wrong
time for bed yeah so you can't do that
anymore it's JP so I guess if you were
going to go the launch of route I would
look at this source but longitude which
is in a 0 to P and use as a starting
point and beyond that I guess we need
some more details of what you're in
exactly 20 yeah that's better hey next
yes yes um I'm go on for Nick and rich
can we see what's going on in the
hackathon uh yeah I'll try and get
mobile device through there in a minute
cool the Knicks apt i'll see if i can
join problem we've got one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten we're
already fully booked we've got all ten
users in the stream right now so i might
this device with me and hope you visit
no there's already ten pic than the hell
so if you leave the Hangout you'll be
able to see I'm glad in a bit if you
tell me that you need the space i'm
quite a bit to drop out no it's fine
we'll leave it to the last five or ten
minutes of the Hangout because there's a
good chance we'll drop
was walking around the building and then
I'll take this laptop and turns back
from space and you can see it that cool
thanks we'll jump over there and see
what's going on because if your pictures
on my Google+ page if you follow your co
Google ok so just go to the next
question have you got one lined up there
Sparky I do let's see how to manage the
ICS incremented use of memory for
high-density graphics my apps are using
up to 20 megs pre ICS but with i seein
as it goes up to 60 MX plus that's too
much heavy else crashes do the lack of
memory etc the is there not a something
that you could put into your manifest
that says I want to use an extra big
system heap the game probably shouldn't
use but otherwise life sounds like you
might be storing broad tiff files or
something in your xhdpi told wall put 60
megabytes in traffic so is well on this
question how would many ways it divides
us I mean so anything's going to change
in ICS good a memory handling or is he
just saying like the ICS era with HT got
a higher resolution like time you guys
in typical I attempt it's the latter one
now we go for HD record this is not slow
into the use of movement yeah so each of
these devices like you know hi
resolution screens everybody have a
higher Iraq memory which you can and you
can get on you by the Henry info last
all right I coming with an end the class
and this class which can query and say
what's my limit and a good way to do
this kind of thing is to use image
cashier so that you know there's a first
level where you're cashing it to an
in-memory cache in there if that cash
gets all you're putting it out to disk
and so on and there's a bunch of great
implementations of that most of them
based on a lie you Cassius so there's
good talk at Google i/o by Jeff sharpie
and about writing and apps which go
through such a cat fashion fermentation
and that talks about how you would sighs
it based on the map memory
why so that's one one strategy but
having like a clever caching system any
other advice you guys I'll so let's just
put a link to memory but I to
traditional get memory platinum e-class
este happens any happen but one that's
me give you all the details about what
you got available yeah and I think it's
just talk test about using me mother and
memory they look slaps aside with hatch
they might want to keep say half of your
memory aid with the images but if that's
what you're actually knows there's also
the the recycling bitmap information
which might be useful with that a lot of
bitmaps being held around your memory
yes very good blog post on android
developers blog yeah reused bitmap
objects in recycle as soon as you can
and I think Chris Bane's also has a
great and recycling get map cache and
implementation on github with anyone
with and keyboard ever internet can find
a link if expenses that github they'll
be most appreciative it does have a nice
solution also ya gotta say there's 60
megabytes sounds along yes or even acts
as well that you will just acting like
large sized bitmaps and putting the
full-size bitmap in memory and then
resizing it when you're setting it so I
definitely don't do I definitely only
open you know do the thing where you get
the bitmap bounds and only open it a
certain size at which you want to
present it so never keep it all thing
and resize it especially if you're doing
your own custom drawing where you're
actually resizing in in your own bra and
very kept revising that another thing to
consider i think it was in the green
droid bitmap recycling the listener for
memory warnings and then the minute they
received that they kind of they're out
there bitmap catch and i don't know
whether that's here there's an absolute
last resort or whether you just should
be avoiding that situation it will cross
and more try an account
actually plug an iPod up and there's the
new cool backs introducing icfs right
there this on trym memory which will get
before on low memory and so this is all
covered in in net torque from Jeff
Sharkey I oh so I strongly encourage you
to check out our yeah we suck silent
that's the point at which you trim at
your cash yeah yeah sounds good um yeah
the action never get some point that it
crashes any way I could get behind on
what was that Sparky so I think I could
definitely get behind that last comment
of yours the app shouldn't get to the
point where it crashes I like that I
think I can live with that big place
thanks out the link the link oh it's a
youtube link for the Jeff sharkys I hope
you can also find that I also it's also
such a bread yeah cool a more live
questions got loads more appearing in
the moderator though ah salons Anakin up
offline documentation for android 4.1 so
he can share it with other developers
he's downloaded it three times but each
time the Android training is still
active and record of zero I think this
is more likely because it probably
hasn't changed having ahead finish new
class is added to enter a training for
4.1 but maybe you already maybe you've
spotted a class that is online there
isn't offline but it's most likely that
we just haven't added any new classes
since the package was built my
understand is that each time we push an
SDK release the docs team rolls up the
documentation site and they put that in
the SDK as well I think that's what I
think that's what they told me there's
also part of the android open source
project there's that some training
documentation all the development
samples are in there as well so if it
does look like there's a problem there's
the ability to contribute
back to the AOSP and make tweaks in that
that hopefully get rolled into next
release Waldo SEK it's updated you'll
get the latest cut been so in light of
that I would guess that if if he's not
seeing any new classes it may just be
that there aren't any unless you know
unless he can identify something that's
missing i would go with that ya boy rich
you write the questions are flowing in
here Rob em was not looking for tips on
developing a lock screen widget there
isn't a lot of documentation on that
however I did find I did find some
information about it on stack overflow I
just found it by searching for it so you
probably can too or if you look back in
the in the archives of of these hangouts
go back maybe two or three months I
think you may find it there so we have a
it's very vexing widget and then looking
most of the hosts which hold them and to
work standard which I feel I say you
should be exactly the same way to be
able to write you now they mentioned
that I think the question was that we
have some information about lock screen
widgets that are sort of officially
supported for honeycomb and beyond and
and one of the objections that people
have as they say i want my lock screen
to work on gingerbread and before as
well and that's where you have to get
into the the unofficial stuff and look
at at what the the people have done on
stack overflow so one of one of the
authors of one of the leading lockscreen
packages basically posted to stack
overflow and said this is how i did it
why not trying to me use the it was
trying to see how it's built on
version you want to implement just
extend it to what you want to change
maybe the heusen basically have the base
class already implemented on more
application it's like a pretty good idea
should we move on to the next one yeah
and see oh baby was trying to ask
question when I was talking about
started asking that I thought oh right
to do ask you a question Ravi um yeah
I've been posting it on chat actually um
that's fine I can ask you I mean I heard
it from google I will that Android would
be strictly monitoring the applications
that were paid on google play and
someone would be downloading and
installing the apks will be having some
strict reinforcements in considering a
downloaded application so what has
happened with it I mean I haven't seen
any restrictions of people downloading
applications from third-party sites and
Justins telling them on their phone i
think thats related to the encryption
that was coming in jellybean for paid
APK well the encryption is in I think
there were some issues that had it that
it was backed out for a bit I think it
is back again alright so the devices in
which I sporting a 4.1 and less than 4.1
will not be having any kind of
restrictions / d stuff if I'm true I
don't think there's much that we can do
for for devices that are running early a
release of the OS that comes before it
knows about the encryption because you
know how would it I guess I don't I
supposedly if we updated the market
client or the Google Play client maybe
you could change is the package manager
involved as well ok I'm ready wants to
step in jellybean
me that's the problem with the those
darn legacy devices screw up all your
wonderful new technology I'll be Justin
here so what does he actually heard of
your delay on it was about hacking
Christians are you asking about oh yeah
oh yeah we install from unsecured
sources to take lot of things um no then
when have when I just watched the launch
of Nexus 7 which is about the jelly bean
and yeah that's that's where it is
lyrics next okay Houdini has a couple of
questions following up from previous
discussions he was talking about the one
by one settings widget saying isn't that
really a shortcut because it can be
placed in a folder which I thought was
exclusively shortcuts back to the
original question how do you create a
config activity for a shortcut and then
he asks a related question which is he
says my main use case for creating
shortcuts is replicating place on home
screen that is an overflow menu for the
people at how can you do that with that
widget so you can scriptural cuts all
together so there's actually that kind
of blow answered for creating shortcuts
there yeah the key is to get to create
shortcuts permission isn't it yeah just
look over search of the create your foot
foot poor intimate inspections I have a
midget which create shortcuts I think
and
well if you have another place you have
a bus in charge the widget on empathy is
there a way to do the same with widgets
so I can skip shortcuts no there's no
way inside replication of having a
button that you press which does nothing
but imagine that it's really did the
user has to install the widget right
sorry yeah I think we we actually agreed
on that one that's the question whose
answer asking anything really better
yeah it's been trying to ask this
question since since google i/o we're
trying to find a button type witches to
the home screen so there is an API
banning a shortcut yeah five minutes
interesting needs amended zap was only a
wicked so just just say the app won't do
anything unless you install the widget
and then you'll have us widgets or just
a lot of uninstalled that no ratings but
yeah I think we got to the bottom of it
in the end and no it's not possible next
joined by a couple of new new people
live in the Hangout we got Prakash we
got Quint do you guys have anything you
want to talk about here on the Hangout
ok well let them think about that maybe
take another question for the moderator
so Ashton says I want to make a custom
calendar view wherein i can show events
match fixtures in date cells how should
i go about it thanks let me start from
the end home to be again in a as me so
are you thinking like take that in
subclasses and/or can can you just
override layouts maybe how much like how
much customization do you think is
necessary to do something with that this
what you might do you might even be
better off game from the Condor app
itself
tensley trying to achieve I don't clear
on exactly star energy trying to show
and what about the gig that iof as well
that might be a good one if that's so of
what you wanted to sort of implement
okay so a couple great sources look at
the AOSP calendar app or the google i/o
app you know i probably start with maybe
condo it's just saying similar welcome
come to view the actual calendar if you
go to like the month view it sounds like
what you want which you know draws a
month and has little blobs marking
events so i see what i could learn
borrow steal from that open that we had
a question not too long ago a month or
two where somebody wanted basically
wanted to take their own private
calendar data and kind of mash it up
with with android calendar data and
display it in a calendar and i seem to
recall that what we came up with at the
time was more or less they would have to
create their own UI for it that we
didn't have a way to just enhance the
existing you I of the existing app so it
is that that the way to do this is going
to be to look at the source code of one
of these already published date viewing
apps io calendar or whatever and and
actually get really get down in there
into the UI and basically we come copy /
reinvent the UI okay can I make an
Android app for just three people to
have without putting it in the store yes
absolutely we call that side loading
which basically is installing by a means
other than google play and in order to
support stein loading your users have to
go into settings and from settings going
to security and select the checkbox that
says unknown sources and in this case
unknown sources is pretty much anything
but the google play store once they do
that the easiest way to get
of just three people your apks to attach
it to an email and email it to them when
they read the email on their device then
the package manager will offer to
install it clear I think and as you get
increasingly sophisticated is everything
you can do so if it's just small like
something like Google Drive or Dropbox
is great for you know always sharing the
latest bill but as you know if you get
more requirements kind of like you have
more testers more people who you want to
disturb its attitude there's other
solutions out there like is one called
tokiya which is then I've heard one of
people using so you can use that to
distribute your app to other people it's
not like and riders thought when you
said that what I immediately thought it
was hawker which I seemed recall was
popular a couple of years ago as a way
of sharing things with people that know
those guys still around I that was that
was something that it was a little bit
like bump only it worked over a dense
distance where you had your
accelerometer and you took your device
and you kind of you kind of want to like
that almost like you're throwing a
frisbee and then they could catch it and
and that the devices would talk to the
server and they would correlate
correlate the accelerometer reader
readings and figure out who threw what
to whom doesn't ring a bell with anyone
in chime cer it doesn't with me but a
quick thought is if you're developing an
Android app you can use NFC beam to send
a URL between devices so if you wanted a
quick way to do it hosts the APK on a
web server and update the app so the NFC
being sends a URL across and the other
device should be able to open it up and
install it I thought about that I also
thought that a small a small developer
who's going to get an apt k to a couple
of friends quickly is more likely to
have email than a web server truth
drivers way to go there yeah we'll drive
good one I I hadn't taken ah that would
even slipped my mind that's a great
answer to yeah I like you who drives in
you can update in make sure everyone has
the latest version
okay all these all these questions that
keep on splitting our opinion multiple
different ways it's number one right arm
for just the whole theory for
suggestions which of the weight it
should be right let's see oh you people
have to stop voting on these questions
new questions are coming in and they're
getting voted up and filtering to the
top of my list moderator maybe in the
future maybe in the future I'll lock the
moderator just before we start to hang
out so so a word to the weary get your
questions in before the Hangout begins
if you want an in-form to answer yeah i
just switched from c2dm to GCM but
sometimes my mentions messages don't get
delivered to all devices when sending
them as a batch the devices are all
linked to the same Google account does
that mean it will only deliver them to
one no in my region if the GCM doesn't
guarantee delivery of any message so i
am not aware that it restricts multiple
devices on the same account from each
receiving the message i hadn't heard
that anything about that so i would
guess that's probably not the case it
may just be vagaries of delivering lots
of applications that you'll have
installed you get notifications across
all your devices at the same time GCM as
long as you've got the the ID right as
the device sends up and register with
your server you may have issues that
you're not correctly supporting both
c2dm and GCM at the same time if some
devices are still on the c2dm version of
your client and some devices of
upgrading to the GCM version of your
client may be one or the other aren't
getting the messages but it's flat yeah
well you've got to support both 32 dmn
GCM and both end points on our server so
we can send the right message to the
right clients so you'll be sending two
sets of messages if you're still doing
the upgrade especially if you've just
switched over it's likely to fall into
that bucket so make sure you've got an
old client that's still on c2dm and a
new plan
it's on GCM when you're doing your tests
only if it's not that then yeah what
else said that we don't guarantee
delivery but it it should it's
definitely not down to us excluding
devices because they're on the same
google account and Andrew Kelly has one
other question he also asks if I have a
gridview how can i get the last row row
to be centered if i have an odd number
of items to the grid currently it's in
the left-hand column of the other items
actually have announced I've expected in
the left-hand column unless you can add
a foot into grid views but you cannot
miss cute maybe you have a footer item
if you've got an odd number of items you
put it in the footer any suggestions
from the Hangout and its face the
writing yeah maybe you usually leave i'm
actually just as a filler to be in the
right end for them that they won't
extensively lyrics but the safety is
like three columns and maybe get one I
was three pollinate do that yeah I was
imagining two and then left in life
no he wants the sentence room is because
my would probably say that this sounds
of customer layout review probably want
to extend wiki and change so this layout
metric dude this is it seems last reply
I haven't done this of good you but I I
had a question a little while back where
somebody wanted to send her an even
number of sort of a mix of even and odd
numbers of elements in this case buttons
in a relative layout and what I
suggested was creating an invisible or
see a non-visible textview center that
and then place all the other elements
relative to that so so a space or item
or an invisible view of some kind of
maybe a way to go here I'm not here
extending Vicki like and let me know
you're still wrong way yeah that's it
what nicely the adapter I'm trying
rounding never gay announced see ya
justice dear it's fine and that was the
last question from the moderator let's
aw nuts a for a I'm lost them I've
got a bunch more actually ah well we've
only got three minutes left to the
hangout and I was going to do a quick
run round to the each and every rose
well why don't why don't I talk through
some of these questions while you take a
walk maybe okay I'm unplugging the
ethernet so that might drop me off her
stuff I'll just read who he is frozen so
adventurous on the moderator says we
decide we described how to make use of a
drawer been documented or providing any
implementation advice well that's true
it's so new that that basically the
Android team had not early the the
framework team had not yet caught up
with the practice so looking
stackoverflow there's some Stack
Overflow threads that give links to
projects that implement various versions
of the of the left-hand drawer and look
and then of the the-- look to the
YouTube application as the way that we
recommend that it be implemented in
terms of behavior oh I see some I see
some motion there from that rich yeah
I'm sure you can see it's actually the
student beautiful day here in Tel Aviv I
just thought I'd stop on the balcony for
a second to make you a kind of jealous
when was the last time you saw a scar
like that in London it's been a while
since I some countries that it okay
let's see i'll take another question
from the moderator while he's walking in
my UI thread i started tasked to do some
long time calculations how can I weight
properly in the UI thread to get info
about finishing the task without
handlers you can you can post progress
updates from your async task and you can
also
you know complete the task by by doing
something in onpostexecute and we have a
couple Android cardboard Android rich
what are we looking at said I'm a
feeling they're just frozen oh well they
stepped into a kind of stepped into a
lion's den of developers there they're
probably using every Wi-Fi channel got a
couple of new people in the call we got
fellow co register any news from Falco
okay
you and we recommend creating a library
android project to validate
you
there's always a good idea maybe not for
something like a spinner or a drop-down
list but if you're taking anything from
a text view or a text edit definitely
validates and I back in Israel okay we
are back with all right here's the
hackathon happening in the college right
now with the jojoba good yeah this is a
really cheap live stream the android
developer officers what projects you're
working on I'm working on I i'm working
on a it's a kind of application that
integrates google drive API to
distribute every files related to events
if you're in attending a google i/o then
you have to download of the plantation
drop to Europe inside your google drive
matical thanks thanks so I want to see
what other projects are going on you
want to finish it off there nah keep
going around the room it seemed
interesting okay whatever else like to
tell the world what project at work not
at the moment what project you working
on yeah I'm killing Buffalo oh yeah
um we're doing get um stop kidding don't
feed it yeah or products no it's very
invested in application that one saying
all Android devices whatever products
you want to subscribe to and every time
the build machine built a new version it
upwards everything to your drive and
then oh if I say is very music there is
kili owners what actually as you may
have guessed this is actually a google
drive / android hackathon so lots the
projects going on at Google Drive
produce as well this excellent little
addition to your build system
upload your files as you're building
them straight to Google driver let all
your users test them the latest version
of the apps as the very hot we'll leave
it at that with the way of the time
already much for them thanks for the
tonic only if you pick up yeah it's
alright but thank you very much we're
gonna leave it there I will catch you
again next Wednesday thanks guys alright
thanks everyone for showing up once
again giving us another great excuse to
to fill your heads with lots of ideas
about android development and we'll join
you again at the same old two o'clock UK
time 3 clarke central european time next
wednesday take care of Ulan that's well
thanks week see ya like